that's okay we got plenty to talk about
we'll probably run out of
uh time before we run out of subjects
it's uh it's really a treat to talk to
david pharrell it's a kind of a change
up from the
podcast you've heard lately with neil
degrasse tyson
and with michio kaku and
and other luminaries of the astronomical
variety
but but today having david perel who is
an up-and-coming
star building on our intrinsic
capabilities
and hopefully upgrading them giving us a
life 2.0 as past guest
max tegmark classifies life life 3.0
david is
artificial intelligence and as einstein
said i don't know what weapons will be
used to fight
world war three but world war 4 will be
fought with sticks and stones
but so i don't know what life 4.0 will
be like but you guys building a
second brain you and your partner thiago
forte
i want to have you on and a big fan of
your work and his work and
i just wanted to showcase what you guys
are doing for my audience so welcome to
the into the impossible podcast
thank you so much it's a real honor to
be here it's kind of crazy how many
guests you've had that i of people i
just really admire and look up to
yeah of course i i became aware of your
work um
i don't really remember exactly how i
found you but those are serendipitous
uh things that add delight and intrigue
to the to the
life uh but my main motivation is sort
of a personal one
which is to enhance um not only my brain
but
in so doing enhance my brian and so i'm
interested in building a second brian
uh but before we get there i think of
what you do
as providing the most critical skill
that is also the least taught
and i'm saying that as a scientist as
someone who works with engineers
we have almost no training in how to
write
for our audience but certainly for a
non-technical audience
and lately my big crusade if you will
is is that scientists have a moral
obligation
to explain what we do to the general
public because you guys out there paying
my salary uh via your taxes assuming you
pay your taxes i know you do david i
know you moved to texas
uh but nevertheless uh you pay your
taxes
uh so tell me why is it the most
important skill and yet we teach it to
almost nobody uh in this field or almost
any other field
i agree when i read scientific writing
the lack of writing education
shows it shows it's not hard to see
that writing isn't taught very well i
mean
just think about it right like to the
extent that scientists believe that
they're
doing important work i believe that
there's
an actual moral obligation to learn how
to write
and to communicate things in ways that
are
easy to understand and clear and
there's always some kind of trade-off
between technical precision
and the ability for people to understand
what is being said
but you know one of the things that i
think a lot about is you know it's
a lot of people get upset with this and
i understand why
but i think that these people provide a
great service to the world and those are
the people who
like bill bryson right he goes out and
takes
a lot of biological research
or anthropological research and just
writes this book
on the body and it's just magnificently
written it has stories
the writing is personal it's
observational it's playful it pops
and it then
addresses the total addressable market
for these important ideas and i think
i really wish that more scientists were
able to write well and communicate their
ideas and i think that those who do such
as david
deutch comes to mind are able to
have a tremendous influence you know
it's amazing you mentioned einstein
earlier
his writing is quite clear and something
weird happened with 20th century
literature with 20th century philosophy
and with a lot of 20th century
scientific writing i mean i go
and i read descartes meditations last
week and it wasn't
easy to read but it's definitely easier
to read than modern scientific thinking
and that was written 400 years ago yeah
i point out that galileo galilei
who's the first really popular science
writer of any
uh he wrote in classic style
but also with modern twist to it and so
much so
was he a a wonderful kind of lyricist
with his writing
that he was able through his writing to
discover new modalities of
the human condition i'll bring one to
your attention right now which i find so
beautiful and it's example of something
that
you've spoken about at different times
but it's called the dunning-kruger
effect
which is basically the steepness of the
learning curve is uh
lulz1 into a false sense of of um
undeserved arrogance and what galileo
said
400 years ago in his dialogue on two
universal systems he said uh this vain
presumption of understanding
everything can have no other basis than
never understanding anything
for anyone who had experienced just once
the perfect understanding of one single
thing
and had truly tasted how knowledge is
accomplished
would recognize that of the infinity of
other truths
he understands nothing and
i think it's so beautiful to look at
this man who is an incredible scientist
he had incredible foibles as well he had
as we all do
uh certain habits certain misdeeds and
tendencies that led to his undoing
and maybe some of that could have been
avoided if he weren't such a good writer
obviously the dialogue got him into the
ultimate home imprisonment in which he
ended his final days
but um if knowledge this paradox of
knowledge
again the topic you've addressed in your
wonderful youtube channel
um in in perel.com in your writings uh
something that you do every day you
write every day and that's a habit of
the greatest scientist in history too
maybe not writing but doing some kind of
experiment and so i'd love to talk about
you know your kind of approach to
creativity and whether or not we can
teach
creativity and or imagination as that's
a big focus
of my group and the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
can that be taught can you teach someone
to be a good writer or can you merely
mimic you know
imitate uh uh previous writers uh
and what is the best way to teach uh
someone to develop their own voice
yeah so
creativity is something that can only be
cultivated but you can't just like
snap your finger just come up with
something creative but you can cultivate
a life that does make you more creative
and
i use that terminology very deliberately
a life that makes you more creative
creativity isn't something that you just
do and you sit down
and it just emerges like creativity is a
way of being
and the
reason why i write every day is because
of
the sort of paradox that i sense inside
of the creative process
which is on one hand it is
true that
history's great creatives have been very
spiky in terms of their
ability to have
a piece of great output you know one of
the things that i find to be very
surprising is how many of the great
novels how many great essays even my own
essays that i'm pretty proud of were
written in an extremely short amount
of time and so
people learn that they see that and they
say
oh great that means i only have to do
creative work when i'm inspired
that means i don't need to show up
most of the days and i say you know what
that's actually not true
because what you realize
is that if you show up every single day
most days are actually just going to be
quite frustrating
but those days where you don't get much
done are like the price of admission
for those breakthrough moments and
i actually kind of think of it like
going to the gym like the most important
days of going to the gym aren't the days
where you're
inspired to go lift heavy weights and
break a sweat
the most important days are the days
where you don't feel like going and you
go
anyway and you leave and you're like ah
that wasn't a great workout today
and it's actually the same thing with
creativity because you never know when
it's going to come
and if you give yourself the space and
the time
to sit down and focus you never know
what's going to emerge
and there's this weird thing where most
days feel a total failure you feel like
you didn't get anything done and somehow
some way you look
back at what you've achieved over months
or years and you're like wow how did i
do all that
and so once you start showing up every
day you have time on your side
where then you're just putting little
bets into the world
and you look back and you're like wow i
actually did something
yeah it's funny you mentioned the kind
of uh length versus time i think
voltaire said
if i had more time i would have made it
shorter which is kind of the paradox of
creativity
and i know that you are also in training
to become a private pilot is that
correct
yeah yeah so i've been a pilot for
almost 30 years now
really yes yeah i've flown uh started
off lying little tiny cessnas and work
my way up and
and uh have aspirations for even bigger
hardware as you know that's an addiction
so
once you've tasted flights you go
through you get your
did you go through get your instrument
and then oh yeah you kept going
yes i have a commercial i have a
multi-engine i even have a
what's called a type rating which is to
fly a specific jet which i hope someday
to be able to do
uh and that's a separate that's a
separate rating and i've started to work
on becoming a flight instructor
and that is in part to work someday to
teach my children i've got several
children they're all interested in
aviation
but i also recognize the adage that
i was taught the day i got my uh my
first
my private pilot's license which was
that
um once you stop learning you stop
living in other words you're gonna
you're gonna start dying in a sense and
because we have to learn from the
mistakes of others as a pilot
the saying is you won't live long enough
to make all the mistakes yourself
literally
i wanted to become a teacher of a flight
instruction now i'm a professor at a top
you know 10 research university and i
was never taught how to teach no one
ever sat me down
taught me how to teach i wrote a
best-selling book
no one ever taught me how to write
scientifically or write for the lay
audience
uh and i think it's so scary it's it's
actually frightening because the faa
as you're learning is a government
entity they have
rules they have things your flight
instructor had to learn what's called
maslow's hierarchy of needs
and that is the needs that somebody um
is requiring in order to
flourish in life but also to teach
somebody something they need to feel
physically safe mentally emotionally
they need to have their biological needs
met um
can you teach that i always think it's
funny because it's the only
branch of the us government like you
can't go into the irs handbook for tax
adjusters
and find like your your people need love
you know like
it's it's not in there you know like the
person you're auditing needs to feel
loved
uh again with the taxes but um but in
terms of teaching the teachers you know
i guess a crispr way to say it is like
how did you learn to teach and is that
making you a better writer
yeah oh absolutely i mean i learned to
teach
by loathing school
like i thought school like i actually
think it's criminal in terms of
just how hard it is on people like me
who are
have some kind of weird mental stuff
going on in terms of like maybe some
dyslexia
just like wires getting crossed and
stuff but in a way that is actually
quite helpful for me in terms of being
creative i also have so much energy
and i just have a need to do things i
have a
need to be social i have can then
i'm sort of over there and get really
distracted easily but then also
have an ability to focus really
intensely
and the thing that i always needed in
life was basically just like
get away from me and just give me the
resources and the tools to help me when
i get stuck
but please just let me do things and let
me go at my own speed
and it was really hard because in like i
remember in college man it was
i took a media arts and entertainment
class my senior year of college
and during this class
during this class i got recruited for my
first job by the ceo
of a major advertising agency in new
york
that when i went to go work there we did
about 45
million dollars a year in in revenue
right so like we're decent size
and he recruited me basically saying oh
my goodness you're 21 years old i can't
believe how what
how well you understand this industry
and
that happened at the same time that i
got a c in my media arts and
entertainment class
and it was just because all of school
moved both
way too fast for me and way too slow for
me so if there were things that i was
interested in such as
the way that netflix and hbo were
contending with traditional cable
networks and how that was intersecting
with youtube i was like oh my goodness
brian this is so
interesting but then there were other
parts of this class that i just had
no interest in whatsoever and the
inability
and the actually lack of encouragement
as a student to say hey
you're interested in this thing go
explore it go crazy
and the gift that i had was my dad my
dad growing up
any single thing that i was passionate
about he was like
dude just go for it i mean we lived in a
family that didn't
like we didn't do gifts we didn't do
birthday presents we never really went
out to dinner
we didn't really do many extravagant
trips i mean when we did trips they were
really focused around learning
but the one thing that i was just
totally spoiled with
was if i wanted to learn something i had
an unlimited an unlimited budget of
my of money wasn't that expensive but
the thing that was the gift was my dad's
time and energy and encouragement and
growing up for
18 years under that whether it was
aviation whether it was baseball whether
it was golf
whether it was one time in 2006 i was in
sixth grade
we had this project called the i search
and basically you're just
supposed to pick a question and
go answer it whatever and so i'm like no
this is not whatever i'm going to get
really into something so what i did was
i
asked a very simple question how will
the boeing 787 fly
and the boeing 787 wasn't supposed to
come out until 2008-2009
and this was 2006 when i wrote this and
my dad had known someone from the
schweitzer family and the schweitzer
family they're
behind the one of the big glider
companies and i think that they were
bought by boeing or affiliated by boeing
so i mean we fly
up to seattle we go to the boeing
factory i touch
and feel the first ever boeing 787
airplane
i come longer than the average student i
end up getting more than a perfect score
on this project
and this was from somebody who got
terrible grades
who i mean i graduated from high school
with a 2.8 gpa
i got roughly average
marks on the act and the sat the two
standardized tests i mean
i say with no hyperbole that i thought
that i was going to be
kind of a failure in life for the first
24 years of my life
but this one project i got the second
best grade in the class i will never
forget my friend alex who did better
than me
and i think that this just gets back to
my main point about learning and about
teaching like
what if for a certain kind of human
and maybe it's five percent of the world
maybe it's ten percent i don't know
somebody smarter
than me can do the science what if the
idea of like
curriculums and and going at a similar
cadence in the whole class maybe that's
just totally wrong maybe certain people
actually need to just be more
unconstrained in what they're able to do
and the problem is that's a high
variance strategy if you do that you're
gonna have some people who don't do
anything
who just sit back and say you know what
this isn't for me i'm just not even
gonna try
and you're gonna have other people who
just go crazy and the thing with
most education policy that we're trying
to do is lower the variance we're trying
to
be have more equal outcomes and
look we can debate the merits of
equality versus exceptionalism as eric
weinstein says
excellence versus genius but
fine i'm happy to have that debate but i
think it's really important for us to
acknowledge the trade-offs that we're
making
when we try to narrow the distribution
of outcomes
yeah it's interesting that you bring up
your you know high school
uh you know struggles that you had
yesterday as i mentioned i talked to
neil degrasse tyson
and he you know he did he said he did
well on the uh sats
back in the day um but he didn't do you
know phenomenally well on the verbal
uh component of it and then about 10
years ago he got a letter in the mail
from the educational testing services
and he was like oh no they thought you
know they they think i cheated or
i don't know they they're they're coming
to revoke my score which
it was good but it wasn't great and he
opened it up and it said dear dr tyson
we're writing to ask you if it's if we
have your permission to use
um some of the the pros from one of your
books as an example
for the upcoming sats you know in the
future so basically be like a writing
sample and then people would
would analyze it you know for example
and he was like i
i would react wow you guys want to use
losing the nobel prize
and he was like after you like you made
my life a living hell these standardized
tests and i didn't fit into all the
boxes
and i had to work my ass off and and now
and eventually he gave them permission
but just hearing you talk about those
struggles but kind of the only clarity
that you achieve in life is sometimes by
looking at it in reverse
um and i'll get to questions i ask you
know what would you advise uh
you know your 20 year old self i mean
you're still so young it's it's amazing
how much you've accomplished in such a
short time
um but i want to turn to your process
because we can say one thing on that
real quick
so two things the first is standardized
tests are so tricky because
so i have a friend named rob henderson
and he
grew up without uh he was he was an
orphan and
he he his parents were nowhere to be
found growing up
and the reason that he ended up getting
into yale was because his standardized
tests were so
were he had such high marks and so i
think that the
the sort of the subtlety of the
standardized tests right now
is something that we need to be a little
bit more
intelligent about as we talk about them
societally because the thing is
standardized tests for people like
myself and maybe neil degrasse tyson
just
don't measure some sort of ineffable
quality that is absolutely true
but the problem is a lot of people say
that and they're like oh it doesn't
measure intelligence like let's just ban
standardized tests
and in another way standardized testing
is
as far as my read on the data one of the
most
equitable tools that we have that allow
allow people who don't come from
traditional backgrounds to prove
their their merits and their
intelligence and
i was reading about this last week and
it seems like
standardized test tutoring and stuff
actually isn't as effective as we think
in terms of people's ability to get
better and so
i do just want to say although
saturday's test didn't measure something
for me i
do think that there are really good
things about them and i haven't
like i would like to see sort of more
nuanced takes on things the other thing
with um with neil degrasse tyson he said
something to me that
was absolutely life-changing so i got to
interview him
in 2016. i just graduated from college
and i went in into his office at the
museum
of natural history and you know it's
really cool
because usually in life life-changing
things you don't know that they're going
to change your life in the moment
interviewing neil degrasse tyson when
you're 22 years old you know it's going
to be a life-changing day
and so you can like prepare for the day
and so i go and i
go into his office and you know i
interview him similar to how we're doing
it but in person
and he said something to me and he said
you know i said how do you communicate
so eloquently you're just a
masterful speaker and he goes
everything that i say in public
is something that i've written down
before
and i'm thinking myself there's no way
that that's true
i get that you speak eloquently but
there's no way you talk
all the time how could it possibly be
that it's something that you've written
down before
and in retrospect now that i've written
every single day
you told me to write every single day
now that i've done it for
five years now i know that that's true
yeah and if you
look at neil degrasse tyson's ability to
speak well
a lot of that is a result of the
diligence that he has to write
consistently
yeah and even more than that i made the
mistake of you know asking a question
which i knew the answer to
uh but i wanted him to elucidate it in
his
uh inimitable way and i said um
you know in in early in your life you
were encouraged more to pursue
athleticism
um but you you know you were able to
succeed in academia
uh despite you know kind of the
stereotyping of you know that he should
go into
athletics and you know it was that just
that self-confidence that you had is
that a byproduct
of of you know natural gifts that you
had
and he said wait a second you know like
basically
you know he said i'm gonna play the race
card and i was like holy crap what do
you mean you're gonna play the race card
on me you know
um and and he said you know your that
question
assumes that i was if i'm born with
something
that i didn't also do a tremendous
amount of work and he went through this
vignette and you'll hear it on my
podcast when it comes out next week
but he went through his his meticulous
uh preparation process when he goes on
the daily show
or stephen colbert or whatever he
wouldn't just oh i'm gonna go and have a
conversation
he would study past episodes he would
break down
the statistics of how long between
questions does stephen colbert wait how
long
uh in time does he go back to reference
past events
so that neil could have a strict amount
of attention
uh to only the most relevant data and
therefore it was a compression algorithm
and something i know you're very fond of
discussing but um but it was interesting
because i actually knew that he had done
that because i had to use the tyson
technique
which i hope that my listeners will take
advantage of and your listeners i'll
send the video to your your team as well
but uh but the point being that um
nobody's born being a good public
speaker as we already established
but the best ones work the hardest and
and it's and it's what i call this tyson
technique
of treating everything even as seemingly
inconsequential as i'm talking okay it's
not inconsequential to talk to millions
of people on national tv
but yeah talking to a comedian as an
astrophysicist of his genius
you know it's it was it was very
interesting to me to hear
that he put such meticulous preparation
so it's not a surprise to me
and i remember you telling that story on
one of your podcasts about your
encounter with him
yeah so yesterday i um i went to lunch
with an actress
and you know she was on house and then
once upon a time
and she was talking to me about
what it was like how she prepares
and so she's been helping her boyfriend
who's also an actor
on a new a new show that he's working on
and so they were filming in vancouver
and they had
14 days of quarantine and she was like
every single day for those 14 days we
went through the script we talked about
exactly
how we were going to think about our our
facial expressions
our body movements what the script meant
and this was the key
moment it's what i call practice
analytically perform intuitively
where what you do and this exactly what
neil degrasse tyson was doing is exactly
what this actor was doing
you s you begin to know the material
and prepare so intensely
that you rather than knowing the ideas
with your rational conscious mind
you know them with your intuitive body
awareness
and rather than thinking about something
and then doing that thing the ideas work
through you
and so i think what it means to really
be prepared as a speaker
is you kind of go over this mountain of
complexity oliver wendell holmes
said for an idea on this side
of complexity i wouldn't or i wouldn't
give you a fig
for an idea on the other side of
complexity i'd give you everything in
the world
and so i think that what happens is we
start off when we're just bsing
something we're intuitive
in this weird way and then we kind of
get into this rational place where
we're we're trying to perform but our
minds are steering the ship
but then once again we end up
intuitively with with with
excellence which actually comes from the
ideas
working through you in a way that you're
super prepared and i suspect that that's
what neil degrasse tyson
would would say he's doing yeah
um so talk about your uh a kind of
attention to detail which i do think
comes from
attention itself you've written
extensively about your favorite
scientific paper which is called driven
by compression progress
so good oh my goodness by jurgen jurgen
uh you're gonna have to help me you're
getting schmidt hoover
i think at cornell uh uh yes although i
guess he was at uh
garching when he wrote this paper um
what do you make of attention the
attention economy i'll say
one thing and then i want to get your
reaction so sam harris has said that the
most
valuable commodity is not time
because time is fungible in a sense you
can always
you know not watch that cat video that
is playing in the background right we
have time to do things that are all
sorts of wastefulness
attention is another thing uh when i'm
playing with my kids and scrolling
you know instagram or um uh doing
something else
uh thinking you know i'm in a synagogue
and i'm supposed to be thinking about
god
and these existential questions and i'm
like i wonder how many emails you know
are piling up uh i want to ask you do
you agree with that statement that
attention is because i actually believe
there's another commodity even more
precious
and irretrievable than attention say
that again
i'm gonna guess trust what is it so for
me it's
innocence i believe innocence is a
ratchet and paul
that it only goes in one direction once
you have seen something
you can't unsee it once you've done
something you can't undo it and
sometimes you can use that to your
advantage as you said like you're going
to do the work every day it's like
you're going to go to the gym you're
going to write 100 you know a thousand
words
a day you're going to do whatever it is
and so on you know but it also can be
negative once you commit adultery
i'm told it's very easy to do it the
second time once you commit
a robbery the first time is the hardest
and so i've interviewed people
you know david on my show that were you
know war veterans
and they they killed people you know it
was it was their life
or this enemy combatants life and they
killed him and they killed
dozens of people and and he agreed with
me he was like i can't
undo it i'm glad i did it my kids would
be orphaned you know or wouldn't have a
father had i not done it but i cannot
undo it
and for me that meant for my kids i want
to keep them as innocent as possible for
as long as possible
and therefore i think innocence is the
most precious commodity and maybe that
does have trust built into it
because they have to trust you as a
parent as well and you know i'm not
expecting you to react necessarily
to all of this but in in your estimation
attention seems to play
a big deal in your life so how do you
choose what to spend your
attention on i agree it is a valuable
commodity
yeah so there's two cuts on this there's
attention in terms of
where i place my own attention and then
there's attention in terms of the
attention economy
so
just very simply
your life is sort of the sum of what you
focus on
and it sounds trite but i think it's
true
and what
you know it's like a chef if you talk to
a really good chef
they would say there's no way i'm gonna
cook a world-class meal
without world-class ingredients and so
a lot of my thinking and in terms of how
i
collect ideas and consume the world
is high quality inputs
you know the really good wagyu steak or
freshly picked strawberries of
information
and then there's the flip side of
intention which is
the economy of attention that is how
you think about monetization on the
internet and
attention is fine but i don't think that
attention
really converts into meaningful outcomes
without
trust and the thing is you can buy
attention
you can go on facebook google microsoft
apple
amazon all of which have billion dollar
marketing departments
and you can get people to look at
whatever it is that you're selling
whoever it is that you
are you can buy that the thing that you
can't buy is
trust you can't buy relationships it's
and it's actually in the synthesis of
trust and attention
that i think magical outcomes via the
internet happen
and when i think about that uh attention
and sort of how computers can act as a
second brain
i made this point actually to my
children you know kind of building on
what you and thiago work on
this notion that you have um you have a
very good
wet super computer that's good for
ideation coming up with ideas and
creativity and imagination
which a computer cannot do you know i
always say people make so much
david of the fact that computers can
beat any human at chess
computers can beat any human at go my
whole thing is i don't care about
ai i don't care about artificial
intelligence i care about artificial
wisdom
can a computer create the game of chess
can a computer
come up with general relativity just
given the laws of
newtonian relativity i don't think that
they can but
my my focus is on the second part that
computers are very good
at doing things that humans aren't so
good at memorization storage
uh compression etc so i think of you
know this article on compression as sort
of the hybrid because if you can
compress information it allows you to
store
fewer things to reproduce the whole but
of course the definition of complexity
something is more complex the more bits
of a computer program would be required
to
to fully explain it nowadays we hear a
lot about ai
and i want to go into your thoughts
about ai and how that could build a
third brain
perhaps um i am working on a project now
the first time in human history taking
the words of galileo
turning them into an audiobook with the
famous physicist carlo rovelli
and others cool yeah so no one had ever
done it i was uh
i took on this project as part of a
video i did for prager university which
is called uh
galileo's dialogue and i was like i'm
going to read this 539 page book in
a month i mean i i could only get
through a couple of pages of it when i
was a kid
and i said i'll just listen to the audio
book because as you point out you can
listen at 2x speed so that'll be great
and
audible where is it there's not a single
audio book david
of any of galileo's books there's
nothing of newton
and who was a much worse writer in terms
of public consumption principia is
almost unreadable even for a physicist
but galileo as i showed before is
beautiful it's majestic
it's evocative and so i said this is a
shame i'm going to make the first audio
book of galileo's in human history
and if that works we'll continue and do
all of his books because eventually
there'll be about two or three million
words
that galileo said that no one's ever
heard read by italians
and then i said well why stop there why
not dump that into gpt-3
and create artificial galileo galilei oh
and and actually have him as an avatar
and start to think about him
and i and i start to think um you know
maybe
maybe this is not the first time this
has ever been done
if we just take the second brain to its
logical conclusion
eventually we get hyper advanced
artificial intelligence
in which case maybe i'm being simulated
by this intelligent agent to produce
what i think is a work of original
thinking and so i want to ask you where
is the next evolution
of before we get into your speculation
on uh general artificial intelligence
and turing machines and so forth
where are we going in terms of
augmentation of the human brain i want
to turn
galileo into a teacher of physics
because he's a much better teacher
of the you know inclined plane than i
could ever be so i want to make an
artificial galileo
as a teacher and that maybe could make
some kind of
impact on education but where are we
going what's the next brain if you will
in this hierarchical system
well i have no idea so let me speculate
i mean i think that one of the most
important choices you have to make in
your career is are you going to be more
like computers or less like computers
and i think that that's a question to
always be asking
and you know there's there's ways that
i see good arguments for both you know i
think a lot of
at times software developers
and you know want to be more like
computers in terms of
aligning how they think about the world
with the way
that a computer actually works and
to actually speak the language of a
computer you know it's probably the
highest
leverage one of the highest leverage
things that you can do in society right
now
but even within that you know if you
want to think more like a computer in
terms of speaking their language
i think that you then want to
differentiate yourself from
computers and have a kind of division of
labor
where what you do
is sort of like what you were saying a
computer can get really good at chess
but they can't invent chess
they can get really good at go but they
can invent go
and get really good at thinking in
open-ended ways and unbounded spaces
and that i
don't actually know enough about the
science of agi to have a sense of
how close that actually is and
but at the same time i mean i just think
about this all the time of how do you
actually
use technology instead of letting it use
you
how do you actually cooperate with
technology instead of competing against
it and i mean the way that i think of it
is about aligning yourself with
the internet basically of saying okay
the internet basically
what it gives us is you know naval
ravicon says that there's all these
little
the robots are already here they just
are working in data centers and they're
not just walking on the streets like a
like asimov's irobot and
what that means to me very practically
is
that take this podcast what's happening
right now to everybody who's listening i
think of like little minions
who are like carrying the ones and zeros
across the world maybe from indonesia to
south africa to argentina to russia
and these ones and zeros are traveling
at the speed of light
from my mouth into a microphone
then thr under underwater cables and
then into somebody's ear it's absolutely
incredible
and i think it's what it means to be
what i call a citizen of the internet
is to be somebody who is able to
put the internet to work for you instead
of
trying to run and compete against it
because guess what
computers they don't sleep they
can work way faster than you'll ever be
able to
but there are certain things such as
about creativity and
just the humanity that i think we all
crave that humans aren't able to do and
so i really
i'm always thinking about division of
labor asking what are computers really
good at
how can i differentiate myself from
computers and in
the partnership of man and machine i
think amazing things happen right now
yeah i agree so uh we'll look forward to
the building the fourth brain we'll have
to see
how that comes along maybe galileo can
teach writing and physics later on
i want to move to another topic that i
kind of just gleaned from you and i
refer people to both your course rite of
passage
your course with thiago called building
a second brain
and also your website parel.com your
friday newsletter
your monday newsletter uh you don't
write enough david you really you're
kind of slacking off here i mean there's
there's
five other days of the week man come on
but i subscribe i read everyone
thoroughly i click on all the beautiful
links it's a lovely presentation of art
technology science and and wonderful
writing one thing you said caught my eye
a couple months ago
you said strive not for faint and yet
strive for niche fame and you gave an
example which i love you you're writing
is replete with examples
which is what the human brain the wet
one at least needs
in order to construct analogies that
allows for actionable
activity to take place you said an
example of niche fame
is being a professor you know someone
who is uh you know
respected in her his field who can
be you know relied on to give great
keynote presentations
and so forth and i thought you know i
have a proof that david's actually right
because you may not know this but a
fellow pilot and a fellow
uh professor uh was uh was the man known
as neil armstrong
arguably the most famous person in human
history
uh first human to walk on the surface of
the moon well what did he do
after he retired from nasa just a few
years after walking on the moon he only
went once
made that first step less than two hours
on the moon went home so how do you come
down from that
how do you not go crazy as some people
did and really off the deep end from
that experience on the moon
he became a college professor university
of cincinnati
and i thought that was quite uh you know
quite a good proof text as we say in the
talmudic business
that that's actually true but maybe
flesh that out a little bit uh the
perils of fame are
numerous i talked to neil again as you
uh
noted you know he's this amazing person
with his huge gift that
and he's got 14.5 million twitter
followers he told me
during covid when he's wearing a mask
he is not anonymous he is not able to
walk down the streets of manhattan
he is not able to take the subway he
will not open his voice if he is in a
crowd of more than a few people because
his voice is so iconic
um flesh out that idea of niche fame a
little bit
not that i have you know too much to
worry about but what are the you know
kind of the downsides you have 150
000 followers you're not kind of the
fame that will
unless you walk by my house you know
people aren't going to recognize you
but um but talk about that the
trade-offs with fame and internet fame
in particular
yeah really
just shook me was tim ferriss wrote
an article i think it's called 11
reasons not to be famous and i was like
wow i don't want to deal with any any of
these issues
it was really scary it was just just a
life-changing article for me and
the thing is that there's a lot of perks
of being
famous though and so it's like okay how
do we think
about this and what is a categorization
and a distinction that we can draw
between
the kind of fame that we do want and the
fame that we don't want and look
i'm not saying that this will lead to
zero bad things but i'm saying it's a
very different kind of
fame that the internet has actually
enabled and i call it niche fame
so what celebrity fame is is a lot of
people know you
you're covered in tabloids and
it's just more and more and more and
more and more so you try to reach a mass
audience
and you're sort of known for your image
and
then look the lines aren't super clean
so
bear with me here it's just like you
know it's a model right
some models are useful but none are
accurate and
the what niche fame is is you're
known for your ideas and rather than
being well known you're well respected
and the reason why i say that it's the
fame of a college professor
is that what a really good professor
has is the ability to meet really
anybody that they want to meet in terms
of
the people in their field other people
are reaching out to them
somebody will say hey i've been really
influenced by your work and so your
your ideas are actually going to work
for you and then they'll reach out to
you you have all this magical
serendipity
but they can walk down the street and
they can actually open their
their mouths they can take the subway in
new york city they can go out to eat
and they're not like mobbed and attacked
by people because the average person has
no idea
who they are and i think that
what the internet has done is it has
allowed many more people to be niche
famous because now
what the internet did was it
democratized the means of
creation and distribution of ideas it's
way easier to
you know this is almost like producing a
radio show but we don't need to go to
knbr studios in downtown san francisco
to record this you know we can record it
from the comfort
of our homes the comforter of our
offices and then
we don't need to distribute this
over very tightly regulated airwaves
where
you actually have to get permits to go
and
publish stuff on the radio you can just
sign up for a libsyn account and you can
publish a podcast
and because of that the number of people
who can be known for their ideas
has expanded by an order of magnitude
and the internet has a beautiful way of
nichifying things
and you can pick something that's quite
narrow
like teaching writing or being really
interested in physics
or science and then
you can focus on that thing that you
want to be known for not just be totally
unknown to the average person who you
would see on the street
and yet have thousands and thousands of
people who are interested in your ideas
reaching out
and creating intellectual serendipity in
your life
and i think that that's a really nice
way to live
and that nitification just to push back
a little bit on
on you um you have an extremely diverse
uh kind of uh spectrum of talents uh
i call you the liam neesom neeson of of
the internet
you have a very you know broad but a
very particular set of skills that
bad guys need not trifle with um so are
you
not taking your own advice you're you're
not very niche a lot of what you're
doing is
is broad you know you're doing videos
you're doing exposes and
i mean next business you're doing
explorations of peter thiel on one hand
and
david hilbert the mathematician on
another hand you're studying the assayer
by galileo and
philosophy you're going but you're
taking pilot uh flying lessons
um are you needing to take some of the
great david perrell's advice
or are you interesting
so i think that there's a lot of ways to
think about niche because
look on one hand those things look
entirely different
but to me they're actually all the same
thing i
only do one thing i learn obsessively
collect ideas have conversations
and i'm driven by what i find to be
interesting inspired by that paper
driven by compression progress
then i distill those experiences through
writing
through just con and then i
share those experiences and
i do that through teaching i do that
through podcast thing i do that through
youtube videos i do that through writing
essays
sharing newsletters and really what it
is is it's a celebration of learning
it's going out
trying to reject a lot of conventions in
terms of how we should think
and trying to find ideas that are in
the peripheral vision of society that
people are maybe missing
and trying to find those things and just
following my intuition
kind of skip and dance as i
learn and make sense of the world and
then share that with other people
and so the only projects that i ever
take on
are projects that require a tremendous
amount of intellectual curiosity
where i have a team but i have space to
sort of wander
and sort of move at my own pace and just
meander as i go to explore
ones where i can be on the move and just
be create and then share that with other
people and
by doing that build an audience and so
yes on
one hand i'm very sort of broad but in
terms of my skills
which is really just collecting ideas
synthesizing ideas sharing ideas and
then
building an audience through that
celebration of learning it's very
specific
and i do nothing else besides that very
nice well i could talk all day
and as i said we're going to run out of
time because i have to teach a bunch of
undergraduates about the
teaching i'm teaching uh introductory
cosmology for advanced undergraduates
majors in physics so it's a lot of fun
it's what i do in my day job building
telescopes that see
invisible radiation left over from the
big bang
and so i get to teach the brightest
luminaries in the cosmos
that will make the dent in the universe
that we need to make progress
and uh david we've come to the final
three questions that i ask all my guests
from
nine nobel prize winners to three
billionaires
and to brilliant individuals such as
yourself and i would like to begin that
process
now if you're willing to go with me into
the impossible
let's do it okay the first question is
an easy one can you provide
a 16-dimensional unification of quantum
mechanics with the electro weak force
no no i'm just kidding i'm just give me
a hard question
all right that'll be our next interview
it's so simple you'll put it in the
margin
as fermat once said right okay first of
all this relates to our judaic uh
connection that i guess i first learned
of you through rabbi wolpe your
interview
wonderful interview with my friend rabbi
david wilby who i love
and did such a beautiful job on that
interview all
credit to him that interview yes it was
far superior to the two interviews i've
done with him
and it actually brought me to tears in
certain parts so i refer people to
david's podcast
um it's a wonderful podcast what's the
name again it's it's
the north star pocket north star podcast
i love the star i shouldn't
have forgotten that polaris right um so
i want to ask you when you reach the
biblical age of 120 years old
what ethical will what zava ah as we say
in hebrew what wisdom
or values would you most want to
communicate to those
people that will become your ideological
errors
don't be so quick to dismiss ideas you
know what i love about philosophy
is i spend a lot of time with
philosophers and what i love about them
is that they can entertain ideas that
they disagree with that they think are
absolutely psycho and they can entertain
ideas and play with those ideas and then
only make judgment decisions on those
ideas later
and i think our society would be so much
better if people
could wait to make value judgments on
the merits of an idea and actually
understand that idea and always ask what
if it's true
and if you do that you will live a
richer life
for yourself and i think the world will
be a much better place that's beautiful
david
and concise which i love uh the next one
is
also related to the namesake of my
center here the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination
arthur sir arthur was of course a great
scientist but also a great writer and he
um in 2001 a space odyssey he has these
monoliths that are kind of like time
capsules
meant to preserve some information from
a long deceased alien civilization
if uh if you were to be given a monolith
that would last for a billion years
is there anything you would put on it or
in it or about it
uh hopefully not like a cd-rom or
something something that will be
immediately evident if one were to read
it could be short or long
i think i would put access to youtube
i think youtube is just
and i mean this will and i'm sort of
assuming youtube in terms of what it's
going to become
i think video is the most
democrat media and the access that you
have to
anything that you could imagine on
youtube i think will stand the test of
time
and it won't die with the years you
should get to know my friend noah kagan
if you don't know him and
i ran into him at uh at breakfast two
weeks ago
i'll say hi next time you see him
although he's biking across the country
right now
last question for you david uh has to do
with going the opposite direction
on the timeline going backwards in time
and it relates to sir arthur c
clarke's famous laws one of which is the
only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible and that's the origin of my
podcast name into the impossible
accordingly what advice to a young girl
david perrault
say 10 15 years ago would you give to
give him
the courage to go into the impossible
it's so easy it's what i'm going to
spend
the next 10 years delivering this
message share your ideas in public
share your ideas in public share your
ideas in public it is
you have been given a gift of
a phone in your pocket where you can
create media and you can distribute it
for free
you are now
faced with a tremendous opportunity and
do you have the courage to stick your
neck out to share your ideas
and to then receive
all the wonderful serendipity that comes
with it i can just tell you that that's
what happens
and you won't believe me until you
experience these things
experientially and actually feel it
firsthand but
sharing ideas online right now
is one of the best things that you can
do with your life
and the aperture of this strategy
is so wide no matter what it is that
you're interested in
you can do it and the returns on doing
it for years and years
are extremely high intellectually
professionally and socially
i love the way you put it at one point
you said increase the surface area for
serendipity by writing
and also as i i have to commend you
because you know it's safer to take the
you know middle road
and not be too controversial even even
exposing your ideas too much it could be
you know the famous italian saying not
you know when you're right over the
target you get the most
shots taken at you but i'll end with an
aphorism that i love
uh which is that if you stand in the
middle of the road you get hit by both
sides of the traffic
you know so take a side and be brave and
be courageous
as david is find him at perel.com david
underscore perel on twitter where he's
got a legion
i'm just a little bit fearful but also
excited to see what you do with this
army of legions david
uh it's so impressive to meet you i will
not comment on your age but i will say
keep going
and blessing to you and i'll wish you
today is friday
shabbat shalom and i hope we meet again
david shabbat shalom i hope so i'll let
you know when i'm in san diego i would
really
really love to meet and then go tee it
up at torrey pines next i would love it
one of my sons is like a mini david
perrell and he's uh he's gonna be just
like you someday hopefully
he's the one who carries around a paper
notebook so that he can have a second
brain as well
best to you david shabbat shalom bye bye
thank you very much you too